I bet there was a one when my baby can I
love that girl oh yes I wanna be cool
what if ever said he from in the name of
Allah the entirely merciful the
especially merciful
he the Prophet frowned and turned away
because there came to him the blind man
interrupting but what would make you
perceive o Muhammad that perhaps he
might be purified or be reminded and the
remembrance would benefit him as for he
who thinks himself without me to him you
give attention and not upon you is any
blame if he will not be purified
but as for he who came to you striving
for knowledge while he fears Allah from
him you are distracted know indeed they
these verses are a reminder
[Music]
[Music]
it's line by touch ship how you doing
brother
I'm the tsunami ah like one flower
flower captain what does that mean many
people some people you know they turn it
into the Dean show first time the world
these guys speaking Arabic was what
salam alayka me for all the salam
alaykom is the greeting of peace between
Muslims so I'm just saying may peace be
upon you when you respond back to me and
may it be upon you as well yeah that's
what we would people peace solution if
everybody tell us uh we were talking a
little bit about what's the difference
between legally blind right and then the
other one is totally blind and totally
blind yet many people don't know what
was the difference what I mean when you
say that so so for example so myself I'm
legally blind so what that means is is
that I have vision but my vision is so
bad you know I really can't see that
much so my vision is so bad and it's
deteriorated so much that according to
the law of the land
I'm blind so I can't drive a car if you
give me most standard documents I want
to be able to read it to you you know
that night with my specific condition I
have night blindness so at night it's
almost non-existent yeah it's
interesting we were talking a little bit
about what was that convention you're at
with each other the Messick now yeah
and that's like now I was I told you
about what - the wire slam booth yeah
and I was I told the brother over there
and I was like listen man when Eddie
comes back or something just shoot me a
bat signal or something you know make a
loud noise so I could find you and I
could talk to the brother but um did
that we met up and then we're able to do
this we got yeah Angela we got United
now your your wife you're legally blind
yes and your wife she's she's totally
blind and she's actually a convert -
she's a Reaver converse you accepted
Islam
yes she did so my wife she can't see
anything at all yeah you know and she
accepted Islam about 12 years ago
someday level your friends at that point
and you know I gave her Dawa and it was
a conversation really it really wasn't
just like this is a slam and that's it
she was Catholic and we would go back
and forth on different points and about
a year of knowing each other she was
like I want to take my she had I want to
be a Muslim so so at that point
hamdulillah I I was our only Muslim
contact so I learned more about the Deen
to teach her about the Deen pretty much
and the Deen meaning I'm talking about
Islam the religion right so so a year
after her making her intention to become
a Muslim I walked her to a message at a
mosque in Elizabeth New Jersey and she
took her she had it yeah cela took her
declaration of faith yeah for those
people turning in who don't know what
that means that's simply when someone
becomes a Muslim they declare what's
already innately built in them that they
let out that that testimony that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
Creator that heaven earth and the one
who brought this message is same
messages Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
other messengers Prophet Mohammed being
the last of those messengers the seal of
the prophets so that's the Shahada no
for the people that don't know and then
you started together with your wife you
started this wonderful project you were
talking to me a little bit how there is
there's not there's over in the world
what about a quarter million about two
hundred eighty five million blind around
the world
two hundred and how many in the US over
ten million in North America now you
showed me a it's called for the books
where it's the touch and feel for
reading right it'll called what is it
called Braille Braille I was thinking
you can just go ahead and submit this to
a factory there's a lot of them but
there's actually just one yet and in in
the States and North America there's one
major Braille process called National
Braille press literally that's what it's
called
yeah and and the thing is what people
really don't understand about Braille
and blind products in general since
we're not the mass population there
aren't many people producing things for
blind people so it always is expense
it always gets exorbitant it's really
really an expensive project or task to
take to put a book that's in print and
put it in Braille but you've done that
and I'm the defender to none so so if we
go back to what we were talking about
about my wife so when she took her she
had that when she when she took her
declaration of faith and she accepted
Islam as her way of life her next step
was I want to learn more about Islam
okay so and she's someone who likes to
read so we looked and we looked and we
tried to find resources for her in
English in Braille about Islam and we
found nothing
this was quote about twelve years ago
found nothing at all
so we at that point we're in our 1920
things like that you're really young so
really didn't think about moving forward
so fast forward some time to 2016 last
year we she she she really wanted to get
more into the religion and she also
wanted to teach our kids we have three
kids and she wants to home-school so so
she wanted to learn more about religion
for herself and of course for you know
for the kids so we looked again and we
looked and we searched high and low and
unfortunately we found nothing nothing
you know nothing no and how did it now
we have we have you know in Arabic that
the actual Quran in Arabic is available
in Braille and has been available for
decades and decades yeah but we found
nothing now no no reliable sources for
knowledge in Braille about Islam so at
that point you know some circumstances
happened I had a lot of time on my hands
and and then hamdulillah
you know I approached her and I said hey
how about we do this why don't we take
the step in making Islam more accessible
thing to the blind community you stand
that's when Islam by touch was born yeah
she she gets the credit for the name she
gave up with the name so so we just you
know I told that like listen why don't
we take a reliable English translation
and put it in Braille and just give it
out for free you know we don't we don't
charge for these books we give them out
for free so we you know I did my
research just
make sure that no one will know one else
is doing it and I had to learn how to
actually do it myself because we didn't
have money to hire people you know so we
literally went on a hunt for fundraising
you know went around to different
massages a little bit here and there and
did some things online like I think it's
launched good they do they do some
Muslim cloud funding yeah so we did a
launch good campaign from Delaware able
to raise enough money to buy what's
known as a Braille embosser
that's literally a printer for Braille
yes and and you know all the equipment
we need and the initial materials we
needed to put these books together so so
after about a process of eight or nine
months we we completed the the full
English meanings of local on in Braille
all ten volumes you know so we completed
all ten volumes of this book and we
started giving it out for free so ten
volumes they come out to you got a box
yeah that's like yeah how many that's
like over twelve or foot yeah that's
twelve by twelve box right there that's
right yeah so it's not like the same
size as what you'd get a normal no
absolutely not where you could get a
normal translation or normal put on like
something you could stow in your
backpack or even something that's almost
pocket-sized yeah with this there aren't
different sizes of Braille in regards to
making it really small there's two kinds
of Braille there's just a standard
Braille and they have something called
jumbo Braille for people who have
diabetes you have trouble feeling with
their fingertips so so we went the
standard route of course and it's just
one size fits all in regards to that so
so a book that can fit in your pocket
has to be spread amongst ten volumes
just so that we can make it big enough
to fit enough information in there but
small enough that someone can put it in
their backpack and take it with them if
they want to read we're going to take a
break and shall I will be back with more
with our brother here from Islam by
touch
welcome back to the Dean show and we're
with nevere from this line by touch you
got an essay yeah yeah I'm amazed I'm
amazed you guys you and your wife who
accepted Islam
you got started this wonderful project
so there's over 10 million legally blind
totally blind
combined people in the US right in North
America so your thumb Arianna day yeah
how many is there any organization oh of
any organization that's reaching out to
give to share this message with those
ten million well as far as I know and
I've done massive amounts of research we
are the only Muslim organization in
North America dedicated to the blind
community over here so you know there
are many other organizations that are
secular or you know Christian based or
Jewish based or something like that but
nothing nothing from the Muslims so we
are the first to do this hamdulillah
something is not I don't know if you got
a chance to see I had a brother who
accepted Islam and maybe a few weeks
later he was on the show almost he was
blind and we talked about it was amazing
he was blind and it relates to how Allah
is saying it's not the the heart that's
blind huh if not the eyes that are blind
but the heart are you talking about my
man I've didn't I declare no not him do
another knows another brother yeah it
was another brother I know he says that
a lot he always uses that yeah the
brother friend and it's this uh this
brother he ended up we did this a couple
years ago it was amazing to meet him
accept Islam and and the scarcity now of
materials yeah but you do one positive
thing you can listen but again I think
like your wife says in on your website
there's nothing some people like to read
yeah exactly you know the whole thing
with with Slam by touch is of course we
started with this you know English
meanings of the Quran and Braille
project that's that's the base and
really it's to give people choices you
know we want to have the same choices
and when I say we I'm talking about
blind community we don't have the same
choices as our sighted counterparts have
you know so we want to be able to choose
whether we want to listen or we want to
read and have that as an option so and
then also like my wife for example she
likes to sit there and reflect so that
silence between her and the book just
her reading and read you know reading
the lines as she goes and having time to
reflect on these verses you know that's
that's how she gets in touch with the
Dene that's how she you know really has
a feeling for the religion so that's her
preference of course but it could be
something different for someone else and
we also help with that as well
our overall goal altogether is just to
make Islam as a whole accessible to both
the Muslim and non-muslim blind
community I think if any genuine
persimmons genuine and sincere and they
just even if they have access because
many people are reluctant to pick up a
book on Islam because there's a lot of
negative stereotypes or but if any one
sincere and they really want to know the
truth Islam makes sense
absolutely it fits with the innate
disposition that we were created with
worship the creator of the creation now
you have an advantage because there you
were telling me there aren't too many
books for the blind to read yeah now
your organization is trying to make that
happen
and now if you have a scarcity of books
people are going to meet more inclined
to read something when you give them to
them you know if the blind instead of
some people to give them stuff they just
throw it to the side because there's so
many book exactly I don't agree level
but now someone will be more inclined
from the blind community to read because
you don't have too many options do you
know that from what you were exactly
right that's exactly right I mean
especially when it comes to Islam I mean
don't get me wrong there are there there
is a library a National Library of
Congress that has tons of books in
Braille you know but when you look up
the topic of Islam or Muslims the only
thing you could really find are either
books written in a negative connotation
about Islam in in in a in Braille in
Braille yeah they may have Fr oh yeah
they have them or or you may find like a
biography of Malcolm X yeah or something
like that
so when we when we went with this
initiative we really want to go hard on
it first for two reasons number one we
want to make this available to the
Muslim blind community that's born and
raised in North America or any
english-speaking country because to
learn how to read Arabic Braille is like
learning a completely different language
and no one teaches that here no one
teaches how to read Arabic Braille in
the US or Canada or anything like that
when you're when you're a child you
learn how to read in English so that's
why we want to make it available to our
Muslim counterparts so they can actually
understand what they memorize and
secondly we want to make it available to
the 10-million some are blind people
that aren't Muslim that they're not
getting a true perspective of Islam you
know they're getting a perspective of
Islam from social media and and
different news outlets that may not
paint us in the best picture yeah so why
don't why not give them Aslam from the
source from a Muslim you know and of
course we want to make this available to
want to put these in blind organizations
that have nothing to do with Islam like
Guide Dogs schools and training centers
for the blind in their libraries because
they have libraries and I can tell you
one thing in every one of their
libraries there's a Braille Bible yeah
and they make those you know our
Christian counterparts step their game
up when it comes to Braille they put
them out there in mass so um did I now
we have something to put next to it just
to show that you know the Muslims didn't
forget about the blind community yeah
definitely this is very very very
important I think my brother was asking
you the question about now when a person
is blind do their their other senses get
enhanced yes so so that there is a
misconception on that a lot of people
figure you know if one thing gets taken
away then all your other senses just you
know they pretty much get strengthened
it's really it's really a situation of
depending on things more you know so if
for example your job is to lift heavy
boxes all day long you eventually will
get stronger yeah you know so if I'm
blind and I depend on my hearing a lot
or then because I'm depending on my
hearing a lot more that sense will get
keener and stronger and more precise
just because I'm using it more you know
based on the fact that my eyes are
deficient so we use the other senses to
compensate for them yes amazing what
what made you decide to put this because
I've noticed it's in you had different
English translations and again yes not
that's not the Quran this is the meaning
of the crime yes how did the the
originals in the Arabic days and I
notice you chose the Saudi International
which is a really great translation yeah
they're too many others doesn't have the
Taoist oh yeah exactly that like that's
one of the main reasons why we chose
yeah which actually have you met that I
believe it was uh two women yes have you
met them I have not had the opportunity
to meet them yeah so so we chose this
translation actually I could show you
let me just show this book right here
this right here this is Volume one
yeah okay so just explain this to you
Volume one out of ten has each one has
three edges inside or just so like you
know three parts of the Quran out of the
thirty parts right so we went with
international just based on the fact
that it is fairly simple English yes
it's easy to understand but it still
maintains eloquence when it when it
passes on the message of Islam so and
and of course in our modern day English
it's not that D and now when ye Old
English it's not that so so that's why
we went with specifically sahih
international comes in love we're going
to take a break another break the air
our shows on several satellite channels
so they need this break yes I'm good
keep going I'm gonna take that break and
God woman we write back Hannity show
don't go anywhere
Tommy welcome back to the Dean show
Islam by touch we're with the one of the
founders you'll it was your wife she's
not with us today she's also someone
accepted Islam she comes from Hispanic
background yes you know yeah my wife is
Puerto Rican yeah cuz she hooked up with
the organization Islam in Spanish we
actually are together I've been speaking
with the brothers because one of the
things we really want to work on is
taking a Spanish translation hmm and
putting it in Braille as well yeah
because there is a massive Latino
community you know and based on the fact
that like I said she's Hispanic it's
kneeling gear to her and hamdulillah
we're really doing great things when it
comes to Dawa to that to that community
so I think we should reach out to the
blind community as well tell over there
you tell us somewhere any experiences
that you've had in sharing this Deen
with people in the blind community so so
actually when it comes to giving Dawa
and this is before of course we started
this lab by touch generally whenever we
talk to blind people friendly ones and
we tell them about Islam a lot of the
times you do get yam and that makes a
lot of sense it's clear in the
hamdulillah I thought a third board
member you know the board member of the
organization she is a you know she's
blind and she came to Islam from dollar
for myself and my wife hamdulillah so um
so yeah I mean it's it's something that
I feel that can definitely resonate with
the blind community yeah you know there
are many people that are blind that go
through a lot of a lot of issues like
depression and you know you can't cope
with their with their issue with their
disability you know even though you know
as I believe it's a part of life that's
it something that Allah gave you some
that God gave you a nut that you you
have it you deal with it you learn to
live with it and you keep rolling that's
it so I think that I think Islam in
general I think Islam in general
empowers you despite the fact that you
may have something that you may have a
disability so just on different ayats'
and local on different hadith from the
Prophet you know verses and sayings of
the Prophet SAW Allah none of them they
empower you and they make you understand
that this is a lost plan this is what
God has planned for you and you know
it's something that you shouldn't take
as a hindrance but it's a favor from God
and it's I know it's strange to hear
that but people you know once you
actually start looking into this
religion you you start to understand it
I think most of us we take for granted
many of the gifts and the blessings that
the Creator has given us and one of
those is to be able to see ya know and
it's it's remarkable and amazing that
you guys are doing this project to get
this crown out for this is a verbatim
word of god get it into the to the hands
of people to the blind community but
people who can see what do you tell
people who can see but they're
disconnected from the current so so when
it comes to the people that can see that
bet I mean I would always just keep it
as simple as possible
you know Islam is not a difficult
religion or way of life if you if you
based it if you've shown the simplicity
and listen we worship one creator that's
it the being that brought you on this
earth submit your will to that create to
that creator and you're good to go
you know and people with all the other
rituals that go on with all the other
religions when they hear that they're
like really is that all it is you know
and subhanAllah
you see people being very receptive to
just that alone and and that's the whole
thing we want to transfer to the blind
community you know and we like I said
that's the whole reason why we did this
yeah but what about Muslims I'm talking
about who they can see they have the
Quran on their shelves but it just sits
on the shelves they don't have a daily
Oh a five-minute a two minute connection
I would say I would say stop taking
advantage of what you have available to
you you know it's like I said this this
has not been in existence until two
months ago yeah this Braille copy of the
English meanings of the claun but I'm
talking about the one who can see they
can read I don't need anything yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying though this
hasn't been available for only two
months and there's people waiting on
this you have it on your shelf you can
take it with you anywhere you want to go
you could take it with you you putting
in your pocket and you could bring it
with you and you don't sits on the shelf
it collects dust you have problems in
your life and you refuse to turn to the
Book of Allah to find out how to solve
those problems you know when it's right
there so that's what I would say to my
side
counterpunch just stop you know realize
the gift that you have there available
to you and take advantage of it it was
given to you for a reason so use it
because those that don't have the
ability that you have to see and to be
able to freely and easily access access
this now that we have it and shot law
the blind community will take advantage
of it
so you guys should be something that you
should have done as a sighted community
you know it's a shame it really is a
shame to see that people have all these
issues in life and we all go through
hardships but when you have this comfort
there and you don't use it and you don't
utilize the benefit of it it's a shame
and it's a waste yeah soap online that
you can just ponder all day and night
just one of these blessings I look and
you know just sight and hearing and
these these things and it's just amazing
that it took you actually seven it takes
you seven to eight hours to make how
basically the whole day you're working
data to put just one together to put all
ten volume all ten value yeah yes oh so
this so I would I would literally use
like I said a Braille embosser which is
a Braille printer right and it would
emboss these pages you know feel them of
course and and as it completes I would
take it I'd put this comb this binding
comb into a binding machine open it up
and just put the pages through it and
keep printing as I go so it takes me
about six to eight hours to do the whole
thing yeah I'll send volumes so it's a
lot of work it's not easy but I'm the
denied something that we took upon
ourselves and I shall love this is just
the beginning yeah yeah yeah it's um you
giving back that's that's that's uh you
know in today's uh society where you see
many people wasting a lot of time yeah
even even someone
in a position like yourself they could
be sitting there and like you said just
being in a bucket or a tub of depression
and you know cursing God blaming God and
not giving back to humanity you've taken
another route and it shows that when
you're when you're when you're grateful
you're thankful and then you're happy
and even in this state you know you're
you you're happy you're obviously all of
us go through trials but then you're
just you're spending your time wisely
with every second that you spend on this
you're on a lost time clock you know
time lost and you're giving back it's an
active ibadah worship but it's amazing
how many people have sight a milk kept
screaming I just wasting time
yeah one thing I say whenever I go and I
give a whole play you know the talk on a
Friday only telling me pray when I go
give the hoof I say it's a look you know
when the prophets hello I seldom said
that you truly never believed until you
love for your brother what you love for
yourself yeah I said that's all we want
we want the ability to love to read like
you do we want the ability to love to be
accepted by the community as just a
normal person like you do you know and
and that's that's really what it boils
down to and that's really what we're
seeking you know we just wait just
because I can't see yeah I can't see
well
don't think that I'm deficient in any
way exactly you know I mean we have
countless we have so many different
examples from our history from Islamic
history of how we elevated blind people
yeah you know all the way to the time of
the Prophet SAW Allah knows on them you
know examples of how he left the blind
man in charge of the Medina
when he would leave the when he would
leave the city yeah and now when we see
blind people we think they're a charity
case mmm-hmm you know like where did we
go what happened with you guys
you know guys they're doing the work of
you know of just you and your wife and
your team I mean our life priceless it
just just you two that's just just
amazing I mean how little a-- we've been
going around all i've been going around
wife she's uh we have three kids she has
she's carrying our fourth so you know
she inshallah should be coming on the
road with me once the baby's born and
grew older yeah um but you know she
she's the support she proof read every
single book yeah
you know to make sure there's no errors
in them and you know it's me and her and
the support that we get you know
hamdulillah we've been I've been
traveling like I'm hearing Illinois I've
been to North Carolina went to Baltimore
for the iconic convention I went to a
mosque over there and you know people
there isn't been one person that looked
at the initiative that we put forth this
as Wow
I don't see why we need that not one
person have said that yeah everyone that
sees like wow this didn't exist
that's the mote that's the question I
hear the most yes I'm surprised it
didn't exist
more I never even thought this was an
issue yes you know and and 100 lat we're
able to bring this to the forefront and
show people yes this is an issue and yes
our sighted counterparts if you want to
help and be a part of this support us
sponsored books you know help us spread
the world help us spread the word of
what we're trying to do because this can
be a group effort we'll do the work just
be the backbone you know yeah so come to
do that and we've got nothing but
support me where I go any time I mention
this to somebody I've never had one bad
you know one no one said wow that
doesn't make sense
that one's ever told me that so um
didn't I want people from this episode
to derive so many benefits one of those
is a scene that a lot paints of a
picture in the Quran that he talks about
there'll be people who will you know
because as muslims we believe there'll
be a day of judgment but you're not just
going to pass through this life and not
be held accountable at the end of this
life the judge is going to reign havoc
on earth enjoy all the commas blessings
and it disobey your maker the creator
and then he talks about the wonderful
rewards for those who worship Him alone
who do good deeds who live a life of
morality of righteous and he's going to
make mistakes but i love the most loving
kind and merciful you turn to him alone
you know the creator will forgive you
but those who just you know ignore the
signs he talks about people being
resurrected
and then they'll say like why my blind I
was able you know why am i blind nice
because when you were able to see you
you didn't see the signs that I've sent
to you and a lot of sending signs to
people you know day and night and if
people reflect deeply the signs are
there yeah I'm the creator and and in
contrast to that right one thing I
always mentioned to people is whenever I
ask people to sponsor help us you know
provide these looks yeah I say imagine
you sponsor a book and it goes to an
organization for blind people and just a
non-muslim picks it up and reads it just
out of curiosity yeah and Allah guides
them you know and that person gets
married and they have children and their
children have children and so on and so
forth and then come Judgment Day because
as Muslims we know it's inevitable come
Judgment Day when everyone's looking for
every single good deed that you could
find and you're standing in front of
your Creator begging for mercy and this
person that you help sponsor a book for
to help them guide them system comes
behind you
with their entire lineage that came from
that guidance and now that goes on your
scale yeah you know so how did he love
if there's benefit in this and you know
we're going to conclude well the time
now the other thing I wanted to say is
the other two real quickly where the
inspiration of seeing you and hearing
about you and your wife of putting your
time now taking this this situation
you're in taking the positive route and
not wasting time not wasting your life
doing something that is of enormous
benefit for the black community not just
them just for you know humanity and in
general sharing this message in this
route and people can take that positive
message from that from seeing and also
seeing that this life is short wasting
that time at the end you you put on
scales of how many minutes how many
hours go by in a day and how much have I
connected with with the Creator with his
book the Quran with learning this Deen
and how much time am I wasting yeah
second the social media the Facebook
just
getting in conversation are useless
doing useless things we all need a
little bit entertainment you know a lot
but how much time is wasted time yeah
what I mean I think the matter serious
and count you know if you were to try to
count the blessings of Allah
you just couldn't there's too many and
appreciate those blessings you have so
they can be taken away absolutely
so I slammed by touch it slammed by
touch if you want to support us just
learn more about what we're doing you go
to our website WWE my touch calm and if
you fill up the contact form
I'm the guy literally answering the yeah
so I'll see your email Dalian messages
and just please support us anyway
yeah so you guys being legally blind you
can there is a distance that you can see
and still read well yeah I mean it with
a hundred that technology has helped us
a lot
yeah you know there's screen reading
software that reads anything you touch
of course there's magnification software
that can blow up the screen to up to 20
times if you need it
so it's some data you know I can I can
read the emails I can check the social
medias I can do all that stuff so you
know once again it's line by touch comm
it's support us anyway and follow us on
social media you know a slam by touch
made the creator of the heavens and
earth Allah the Almighty rewards you and
your family and bless you guys for doing
this wonderful and amazing I mean both
of us ethics both of us so I wanna go
off the lot well a concern